[Musik]
ja ja ja herr meier ich ob sie
verstanden habe auch schon alles notiert
jetzt passen sie mir im moment ist das
richtig lärmbelästigung aus der
nachbarwohnung durch laute heavy metal
musik also jetzt bekannt berlin kann
also doch das war zu verweisen
das ist eine lustige übermorgen
frühestens das heißt gar nichts zu tun
haben dann brühen deswegen geht es
schneller rallye ikone linz zaubern
bei mir im lokal ist er schneller als
bei ihnen liegt die probierstube ganze
zeit offen zur geburt sie die temporären
mir mein lokal die haben eine ganze als
ich zum kaputt ist sofort der streife
vorbei dass die leute aber sie schiessen
kurven sie analysiert das sofort geht
gar nix
jetzt machen wir es so ich schickte
streifte zuerst die im heavy metal
trottel hin und dann sofort so erna das
war dann in ordnung war übermorgen 1630
die schlägerei ist jetzt ja machen den
termin jetzt fix ja oder nein
bei der polizei termin bis zum
handwerker sein termin oder bei musik
beim vermögensberater daraus ein termin
beim facharzt sagt an seinem finger bis
zu den ellenbogen hinten abschläge wenn
es übermorgen komödianten
warum ist sie haben den treppen zum
schluss aber so dann kommt die streife
zuerst sie einem nachbarn wegen der
lärmbelästigung und dann zu gerne wäre
körperverletzung senkt so gibt ist und
bleibt jetzt bei 16 uhr 30 die schläger
schon wieder weg wie sie manche sachen
von selbst erledigen
wieder schauen
[Applaus]